Oh !
Arrête-toi !
Arrête-toi j'te dis !
Reviens-là sale nègre !
Arrête-toi !
Merde !
Allez !
Bah alors ?
On veut visiter ma cabane ?
S'il vous plaît ! Il faut que vous m'aidiez !
Et pourquoi je ferais ça petit ?
Parce que...
attendez, vous...
vous êtes aveugle ?
Et t'inquiète pas que j'peux te viser d'ici !
S'il vous plaît... il y a...
Il est là !
Il y a deux noirs qui me poursuivent et qui veulent me tuer !
Deux nègres ?
Oui ! S'il vous plaît ! Laissez-moi rentrer !
Tu croyais pas que t'allais nous échapper mon salaud !
Fait chier...
Hey ! Doucement toi, là.
Quoi ? Il veut quoi le vieux schnock ?
Mais c'est un aveugle !
Mec, arrête...
c'est Snipy Pete !
Il bande pas, il voit pas mais il paraît qu'il peut toucher une cible à un...
Et j'entends très bien aussi.
Bon, toi, là.
Tu vas arrêter d'emmerder ce brave type,
et le laisser tranquille.
Est-ce que c'est clair négro ?
Négro ? Mais c'est une blague !
Mais, c'est lui le négro !
Je le pourchasse parce qu'il s'est échappé de ma plantation !
Quoi ?
Non non non non, c'est pas vrai !
Il veut s'en sortir comme il peut !
Tu vas payer pour ce que tu es en train de faire toi !
Hey ! Fermez-la vous deux !
Vous me prenez pour un con, c'est ça ?
Hein ?
Bah c'est ce qu'on va voir.
Comment vous vous appelez ?
Euh... alors moi c'est Bill.
Et toi, vas-y négro, dis-lui ?
Bruce McDermott, monsieur.
Un enfoiré d'écossais ?
Et roux qui plus est.
Je ne sais même pas comment j'ai fait pour me marier.
Hey petit, le plus dur c'est pas de se marier.
C'est de le rester !
Mais... mais... putain, il est tout sauf roux !
Il... il a des espèces de boules immondes sur la tête !
Hey chut... c'est bon, là.
Tu me laisses me faire mon propre avis ou pas ?
Ok, mais laissez-moi vous le décrire au moins.
Ok.
Je t'en prie.
Ses yeux, ses cheveux... tout est noir chez lui.
Mais encore ?
Il est grand...
il a la force d'un buffle...
certains ont peur de lui...
chez d'autres, c'est l'inverse.
Ils l'admirent.
Mais, c'est la description parfaite d'un homme blanc, ça.
Mais putain, c'est un nègre je vous dis !
C'est un putain de nègre !
Ferme-la !
C'est bon, ton tour est passé.
C'est clair ?
Bon, Lord McDermott.
Pouvez-vous me décrire la personne à côté de vous, s'il vous plaît ?
La personne ?
Vous voulez dire l'animal ?
Le sauvage ?
On dit que leur cerveau est inférieur, je vous rappelle.
Pas de doute,
j'ai à côté de moi la pire des bêtes.
Un nez énorme...
des lèvres gigantesques.
Vous savez...
je lui ai répété ces mots tellement de fois...
que je suis sûr qu'il doit les connaitre par coeur maintenant.
Hey ! L'éclopé !
Tu sais à quoi je peux prouver que je dis la vérité ?
L'odeur !
La personne à côté de moi, elle sent la merde.
Et c'est normal parce qu'il est occupé à laver la chiasse de nos truies.
Et grâce à qui il a eu cette promotion ?
Et bah grâce à moi !
Vas-y, l'éclopé. N'aie pas peur.
J'te jure, tu peux le sentir à quelques mètres celui-là.
Rapproche-toi, McDermott.
N'aie pas peur.
Vas-y !
Allez avance !
Avance !
Allez, plus près !
Avance.
Hahaha !
Avance négro.
Si je devais tuer tous les mecs qui schlinguent on s’en sortirait pas, non ?
Il était pas mal son plan.
Dommage que j'ai entendu ses chaînes de négro !
Gling gling ! Gling gling !
Allez viens.
Bah bienvenue chez moi ! Ma petite cuisine,
ma petite femme ! Et voilà.
Tu peux t'installer.